[Music]
you come here thinking there is a way
out of this world for you Mr Wick
there is not
the song
sacrificure
weapons
if you win
the table will honor its word
we will have your freedom
but you want tickets
blades
pistols
dueling pistols
30 paces
in the event that both parties survive
each will approach the other at
increments of 10 Paces until only one
remains
so
you want to kill him
I want to kill him
what about you Mr Big
I'm going to kill you oh for better of
course yeah
but it looks like we have ourselves uh
has anyone conundrum
like wondering if you will a real life
dilemma so
I thought we play a game
one hand
desires who lives
and who does not
[Music]
weak and welcome
to low resistance a little far from home
aren't you well your little Act of
uncivil Disobedience inspired me John
I'm branching up spreading my wings
out goes the ground farewell to him
coming to an end
so it seems so it seems
42 regular wasn't it
it's Kevlar front to back the latest and
Ballistic Chic appropriate for all
formal occasions weddings funerals high
table duels
after all man has to look his best now
it's time to get married
or buried
this
Mr Wick
42 regular wasn't it yeah
And So It Begins
challenging to single combat if you win
you will have your freedom and when I
see you imma take what I want so
amen
on the wall
get bloodied
the only way John Wick will ever have
freedom
peace
[Music]
yeah not really
yourself come on
man
[Music]
you got yourself
we're here
working on John Wick chapter four And So
It Begins
swag cars and weapons
[Music]
with chapter four
we took it to another level
chocolate
[Music]
is out
John Wood movies they're known for Keanu
Reeves doing the stunts it's been about
12 weeks of trim it's new levels of
action you know let's have Moon shots
which was challenging
keanu's attitude and the talent whether
it's handling a gun how it reloads it's
compelling to see him do it
[Applause]
thank you
John Wick action asks just a little bit
more and you see the effort and the
commitment from the team Ian mcshane's
back with Lawrence Fishburne and Lance
Reddick and then we have Donnie Yen
Bill Skarsgard hiroyuki sonoda Clancy
Brown Shamir Anderson
incredible Natalia antenna Scott Adkins
fighting Kiana Reeves
and also we have Arena
you make it look easy but it's not
for chapter four we wanted to bring a
muscle cars back we really wanted to do
something different we're gonna have the
sequence
around the Arctic triangle
we tore all the doors off and lost the
windshield you're gonna do a reverse 180
and you gotta shoot a gun and you gotta
reload he actually started getting too
good in the car
we're smashing people hitting people
it's just amazing we've shot some stuff
that pushes John Wick to the Limit
gone too far
same goodbyes
saying hello
you think your wife can hear you
no
Maybe I'm Wrong
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds
no management we've known each other
since
[Music]
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
love this man
the man has to look his best when it's
time to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
I will have your freedom
that's your laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
results in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
[Music]